hey guys welcome back to a brand new
video and today we're gonna be talking
about a new MMO that has been taking its
time and it's obviously just recently
got delayed but it's been kind of taking
this new approach on invasions and we've
covered this game in the past before but
I wanted to let a little bit of other
people know that are new to this game
kind of what's going on that game of
course is Amazon game studios new world
and we're gonna be talking about its
invasions for a little bit so in the
past video we kind of briefly mentioned
what invasions were kind of like a quick
gist of the premise of it but now this
specific video will be going a lot more
in-depth on everything that has to do
with the specific invasions in new world
and how all this stuff really works so
as always like the B if you enjoy
everything new let's get started with
today's video so on the blog post in the
very first part it says a tournament
mysterious and hostile land where you
will fight to get a foothold and must be
ready to defend it from invading forces
human and supernatural a new world when
the forces of corruption have amassed
enough strength and a territory they lay
siege to a fort this is called an
invasion during the battle the defenders
must protect their fort against
escalating waves of enemies at the
forces defending the fort are successful
the corrupted armies repelled and the
battle is won on the other hand if the
Ford Falls the territory suffers and
loses some upgrades such as crafting
stations for gates and for turret post
battle the corruption retreats to
replenish their force and the fort
resets itself restoring any structures
that were destroyed don't spend too long
upgrading your territory again though as
invasions occur approximately every four
days we do have some questionnaire stuff
at the bottom a little bit farther down
if that says how to participate in said
invasion and it says the day before an
invasion players can sign up for an
event at the settlements town board the
governor of the defending territory
could choose 10 years to accompany them
in the upcoming battle the remaining 40
slots are randomly selected from players
who signed up to take part in the
invasion note that only players at level
50 or above can participate in invasions
now I've stated this before and this is
coming from a guy who hasn't had beta
access or hasn't had alpha access yet or
hasn't really watched much of the Alpha
gameplay this seems to mean that level
50 might be the highest
ranked that we're going to be achieving
I've been seeing a lot of things being
unlocked at level 50 which least to me
seems like the highest rank that we're
gonna be able to achieve now is there
going to be stuff after that probably
not maybe though I had some in a feature
update you know increase the level cap
and such but it seems like level 50
might be the set level cap and then
that's when we can get all this crazy
stuff like invasions and such next is
talking about the preparation phase
before the invasion and it says when
division starts and you have chosen to
participate you will automatically be
transported to the fort with other
teammates and provided with 50 battle
tokens for a brief period of time
players can use their tokens at the
armory to better prepare for the fight
or save them for later to use during the
invasion battle tokens can be used on
powerful ammunition and potions and
Cindy reminds explosive powder kegs and
turret ammo furthermore players can earn
and use additional battle tokens by
performing various actions during
battles such as killing repairing and
healing and then on screen you're gonna
be seeing two images one guy here is
gonna be buying through some of the seed
utilities we got as auth bullets and
Ferno traps mana elixirs as auth arrows
and locates most of the stuff that we
had already just talked about a second
ago that you were able to purchase with
the battle tokens and then a little bit
farther shows him purchasing the new
inferno trap so that he can get some of
that items for the siege and the
invasion but of course he's gonna be
losing some battle tokens for it so now
he's only gonna have 20 which means you
can only buy a few things on that menu
again the next part of the blogpost
talks about the actual invasion itself
and it says that it's battle time after
the preparation period enemies start
emerging from the corrupted portals
around the fort this is the first of
eight waves of enemies so strategy and
tactics especially the battle tokens
comes into effect don't want to estimate
your enemies in this battle you'll have
to adapt your combat style according to
different kinds of creatures each with
different skills and abilities here's a
list of some of the creatures now sadly
as opposed to last video I will not have
specific pictures for each individual
enemy type there's only one enemy in
regards to you know some of the pictures
being shown here so I'm assuming it's
going to be the very last enemy they
show which is the bosses or the enemies
we do have grunts these guys pose little
threat but when they swore
they can quickly take down any targets
they focus on destroying structures if
they can't reach one of them they begin
to attack players after a period of time
they start to frenzy creating fast
intense and increased damage while also
burning themselves out
I recommend destroying these grunts as
quick as possible the Raiders are the
Shock Troopers of the invading forces
they are skilled tough and well equipped
they are more than capable of handling
themselves and melee combat that focus
on attacking players but also will
attack structures if there's no players
within range
the snipers hang back and take potshots
from players at a far the prioritizing
on targets on the ramparts and are
effective at suppressing turrets they're
also evasive and dodging and ducking to
avoid players attacks the Bombers are
runners with explosives strapped to
their back they run at structures and
then blow themselves up dealing
significant damage it is highly
recommended to take them down using
ranged weapons before they explode on
death brutes are huge hulking beasts
with smash structures they will also
occasionally attack players that annoy
them what otherwise found focusing on
destroying defenses brutes are very
tough and require multiple players in
order to defeat and then bosses can vary
some are very focused on destroying
structures while others focus on
attacking players in addition some of
them apply buffs to other invading
forces or D buffs to players and then on
screen we have two different images one
which looks like it's the bomber seeing
as those are spikes in the back of that
dudes kind of backpack or whatever that
stone happens to be I'm assuming he's
the bomber whereas the other picture
looks like this giant brute dude with
the tail and that either looks like a
brute or a boss I think it really looks
more like a brute just based on the
description of both of them but either
way that's kind of what you're gonna be
expecting from two of the possible
enemies in new world so very very scary
actually the corruption will also focus
on destroying the gates first then
destroying the fort claim during battle
players can use various structures to
help defend the fort such as turrets
choppers support and trappers note that
as with Wars only the company that owns
the territory can build defensive
structures before the invasion commences
here's a bit more information about each
of those structures turrets such as
ballistas repeaters and Explosives
provide a means of a to attack an
enemies from a safe distance and prevent
them
reaching the gate droppers are highly
effective against inventory but
ineffective at anything at range the
fire dropper pours molten liquid on
enemies below making it great for
defending the gates support structures
can be used to buff players and debuff
enemies such as the horn of resilience
that provides a defensive buff to all
nearby teammates while the buff is
active your teammates take reduced
damage and heal over time do not
underestimate the horn as it could turn
the tide of a battle if used at the
right time and then lastly are traps and
they are deployable defenses that can be
placed within the battlefield the
players can obtain them from the armory
and use them like any other deployable
throughout the battle players could keep
a close eye on the in-game details by
looking at the information at the top of
the screen this includes player specific
objectives and major time remaining the
current wave of attack and the total
waves and then on screen we have two
more images to look at the first one
looks like what's going to be the
repeater or one of the turret defenses
that you can look at which is really
looking Ronis you pretty cool I think I
has like four or so barrels of just
bullets that you can reign down which is
pretty nice and then on the second image
it looks like we have the explosive
cannon possibly with the drop or
definitely being on the main gate
pouring that molten liquid on the
enemies in the corruption which is
pretty cool and then it says players win
an invasion by protecting the fort claim
until the time is reached the invasion
is lost if the enemies destroy the fort
claim within the time limits after the
battle the corrupted forces fall back to
regain their strength and prepare for
the next invasion win or lose players to
contribute to the battle are rewarded
with XP in-game currency and loot then
they are released back to the stunning
yet dangerous land of eternal should
players be defeated it will cause a
downgrade of their territory players
will receive some XP loot and as alt
depending on how many ways were
completed you can check out more
information about upgrading and
downgrading territories by clicking this
article and then going to that article
talks about one of the ones they
released way back in the past I think in
like February is when they released this
article and this was way long ago that
we've already talked about in terms of
the settlement and the government system
of the game which of course you can
always check out that video if you want
but yeah overall that's pretty much the
gist of how invasions are going to be
working this PvE type of idea within the
game and personally I'm a huge fan I've
always been a big fan of PvE type
content and this is definitely something
that's going to help with the game and
you'll have a head you know just have a
little bit of fun with it and obviously
it keeps people entertained keeps them
on their feet because these invasions
couldn't happen at any point so
definitely gonna be something that I'm
gonna be trying a lot with a new world
let me know what you guys would do if
you guys gonna be playing new world the
only last bit of information I want to
talk about was with the actual delay of
the game I didn't make a whole separate
video on this I was going to wait until
something like this came out and I've
totally forgot to put it in the
beginning of this video but new world
has actually been delayed the entire
game has been delayed I believe it's
August 25th of 2020 I could be wrong on
the specific date but I'm fairly certain
it is August 25th so we're gonna be half
date having to wait a lot more months
just to be able to play the game again
which of course is tragic but given the
circumstances of what's been going on in
the world I think it's totally
understandable that this is happening
but either way guys that's gonna be the
end of today's video like to be if you
do enjoy subscribe if you're new and
with that take care have a great stir
day and peace out
[Music]